Welcome back to the
Pharmacology of the
Cancer Drugs. This
is part two. We'll
talk about the targeted
therapeutics now.
Dr. Goldstein speaking.
And contact me if you wanna
talk about pharmacology.
Here are the
learning objectives
as usual and materials.
I'm going to go right
into the lecture at this
point, the approach to
cancer treatment. Cancer
treatment has evolved
since the recognition of
cancer genetics and the
development of targeted
therapeutics that specifically
attack cancer cells.
The drivers of cancer
growth are the oncogenic
pathways in the malignant cells,
the tumor microenvironment,
so that's the environment
outside the tumor,
and the ability
of the malignant
cells to escape
immune surveillance.
targeted anti-cancer
therapeutics specifically act
on well-defined extracellular
or intracellular molecules
to interrupt the oncogenic
signaling the tumor
growth and proliferation
the targeted therapies are
usually used in combination
regimens including with non
-selective cytotoxic
chemotherapies and other targeted
drugs lots of pathways
this i of course you don't
have to memorize any of
this it's just to show you
that there are numerous
targets in here here's rass
lots of the growth
factors the hormones the
cytokines and on and on
the cell death pathways is
indicated here in various
places so most of these
cancer drugs most of these
targeted therapies are
going to target a specific
point in a specific
pathway or possibly several
points in pathways the
types of drugs that
we're going to be
looking at the targets
that we're going to
be looking at are all
the types of drugs,
small molecule drugs.
So we see small
molecule, these are
going to be oral, and
these will work at
intracellular targets.
We have our antibody
therapeutics that are going
to act at extracellular
targets, growth factors,
growth factor receptors.
We have antibody
drug conjugates,
which is just the
antibody to a specific
target that is
carrying a payload.
And that payload is
some chemotoxic product.
And immune checkpoint
inhibitors,
the idea is to get the immune
system to recognize the
tumor and prevent the tumor
from inhibiting the immune
system attack. And then CAR
T-cells are specifically
designed, engineered T
-cells. They are actually
genetically engineered against
specific tumor antigens.
So I put these in a table.
Hopefully you'll be able
to organize your thoughts
around them. I am putting
this particular part two in
terms of various cancer
types, looking at the drugs
within the context of the
cancers that they treat. and
really this is just a few
drugs there are so many many
more but if you can get
the ideas with these you'll
be able to understand all
the rest and here are some
targets these are the tyrosine
kinase signaling pathways
we tyrosine kinases can
be soluble so non-receptor
tyrosine kinases like the
BCR-ABL. They can be membrane
-bound receptors that
activate tyrosine kinase
pathways. And these various
acronyms underneath are different
tyrosine kinase pathways.
Epidermal growth factor
receptor. Human epidermal
growth factor receptor 2,
HER2.
Vascular endothelial
growth factor is a growth
factor that activates a
growth factor receptor. So
that's VEGF receptor. This
is supposed to be a VE.
And we have drugs that
act to inhibit the cell
cycle, the cyclin-dependent
kinases so those are the
checkpoint proteins and
PARP inhibitors I'll talk
more about those when
I get there and we have
some proteasome inhibitors
that I'll talk about
these this slide shows you
drugs that are actually
used in the treatment of
my multiple myeloma and
immune checkpoint inhibitors
and our CAR T cells.
This is just a little
scheme to help you
visualize all of the
different targets that are
used to kill cancers.
I'm not talking about all
of these, I'll just
talk about some of them.
So let's start with receptor
tyrosine kinase signaling.
I mentioned before
we have the receptor
type, I should say the membrane
-bound type and the
non-receptor type.
And they basically
do the same thing.
They're tyrosine kinases.
You can read these
on your own. The
concepts are all
basically the same.
This is the picture
of a receptor
tyrosine kinase, the
transmembrane type.
This is unbound, unactivated.
Once the ligand binds, in
this case, it's epidermal
growth factor, the
receptors dimerize. They
come together. And in
here, we see P stands for
phosphorylation, so
autophosphorylation, they
phosphorylate themselves,
and that in turn will send
down signals to activate
the signaling pathway.
We have drugs that
can inhibit out here,
and drugs that can
inhibit in here.
I'm not going to
read you this whole
thing. It's important,
though, that you
understand the concept
of tumor vessels.
VEGF, vascular endothelial
growth factor, activates
its receptors, which
are receptor tyrosine
kinases. Now, the tumor
blood vessels are leaky.
They don't have lymphatics,
intratumoral lymphatics.
It can cause increased
interstitial pressure, and
that's going to prevent drug
from getting in to the same
degree as it would
ordinarily do. So inhibiting
vascular endothelial growth
factor or its receptors is a
target to prevent angiogenesis
of the tumor vessels.
Small molecules passively
diffuse into the
cytosol, and these small
molecule drugs have
a suffix of tinibs or
sometimes just dib.
They block the
intracellular ATP binding
site on the tyrosine
kinase domain. They
prevent the autophosphorylation,
which prevents
activation of the
signaling pathways.
All of these TINIBS, no matter
what cancer they're treating,
are CYP3A4 substrates.
There's a high potential
for drug interactions
with these, and
many are also substrates
of P-glycoprotein.
But they are oral.
They're given once
or twice a day.
Very convenient
for the patient.
Adverse effects.
The adverse effects
are related to the
specific targets
that are inhibited.
Growth factors in the case that
we're talking about right now.
Nausea, vomiting, diarrhea.
Rash. This is an
acne form. Rash.
Desclamation of
the skin. The skin
is epidermal. liver
injury, heart,
bone marrow,
susceptibility to infection,
well, bone marrow,
anemia, neutropenia,
thrombocytopenia, hypertension,
periorbital edema, and more.
So even though they don't
cause the same type of
cytotoxicity that we saw with
the conventional drugs, they
still can produce some
pretty serious side effects.
So, monoclonal antibodies now,
MABs, I'm sure you know that,
they bind to the extracellular
domain on specific
epitopes of that
extracellular part of the
receptor, and that
will block the natural
ligand from binding. It
will also prevent the
receptor dimerization and
activation. Of course,
it's blocking the natural
ligand from binding.
they are they are injected
they have a long half-life
some of them are formulated
for sub-q injection and
these are formulated with
something called hyaluronidase
which breaks down hyaluronic
acid which makes the
tissues more permeable so the
drug can get through on upon
sub-q injection them. Days
to weeks for that half
-life, metabolized by
proteolysis in the liver,
reticuloendothelial system, and
also they can be endocytosed
and broken down into their
amino acids inside the cell.
Adverse effects, well,
that's going to depend on
what pathway they're
inhibiting. So the class
effects that we saw on
the previous one, now they
are injected so we can
see infusion reactions,
injection site reactions,
hypersensitivity reactions,
now vascular endothelial
growth factor and its
receptor. So we have
monoclonal antibodies and
we have small molecule
multi-targeted drugs that
will, that multi-target
often includes a vascular
growth pathway. So the
antibodies will bind the
soluble growth factor.
Oh, it says cytokine. It's
really a growth factor.
And by binding the
VEGFA, that prevents
it from activating
its receptors.
the antibody that binds
the receptor now will
inhibit the dimerization
and activation of
the signaling pathway
pretty typical of the
antibody effects no
matter what the target
adverse effects well think
vascular endothelial growth
we're inhibiting that so
we can see hypertension,
hemorrhage,
thromboembolism,
impaired wound healing,
wounds that
actually pull apart,
wound dehiscence. So
this, we think about a
surgical wound that's been,
that's healed and now we
give the drug and it
pulls apart. And of course
infusion reactions with
monoclonal antibodies.
Now that we'll move to our
BCR-ABL kinase inhibitor,
imatinib. I put a star
on and panatinib. Now the
issue, the only thing
I need you to remember
with panatinib is that it
can be effective in cancer
cells that are harboring
this T315I mutation.
Otherwise imatinib
properties can be carried
through to all
the rest of them.
They're tenibs, so oral,
CYP3A4, P-glycoprotein.
They're also highly protein
-bound. That's pretty typical
of the tenibs, and these
drugs are excreted in
the feces. So my mechanism
of action, It binds, and
in the case of these
imatinib, it binds to this BCR
-ABL tyrosine kinase, which
is constitutively active,
and it is a non-receptor
type of tyrosine kinase.
So the drugs prevent
binding of ATP
to the binding site,
and I'll show you
a picture of that
on the next slide.
Point mutations. This is an
example of a point mutation.
where we get the switch here
with the isoleucine
and sreonine.
That'll give a different
characteristic to
this site, 315 site,
and the ABL-1 residue.
Uses.
Matinib was developed for
chronic myelogenous leukemia,
p philadelphia philadelphia
chromosome positive
the initial chronic
phase the accelerated and
the blast phase and since
then it's been found to
be effective in the treatment
of other philadelphia
chromosome positive
genes sorry cancers
the adverse effects are
typical of the tenibs
class so i'm not going to
read them to you again.
Here's the mechanism
of action. Here's our
BCR-ABL tyrosine kinase,
and this is the ATP
binding site that gets
blocked by the drug.
This chart just gives
you a hint about
what all of the
different therapeutic
uses are for these
various drugs,
imatinib,
so Philadelphia
chromosome positive, CML,
ALL, and other tumors,
penatinib, CML,
ALL, and this T315I mutation
that causes resistance to
imatinib. Otherwise they're
all pretty much the same.
They're all, they all seem
to be equally effective.
This is a picture of the
typical rash caused by
imatinib and in this
individual here you can easily
see the periorbital
edema. Imatinib is known
for this and how the skin
and is just peeling off
of this man's face. So
that is the desquamation.
All right, let's check
the knowledge. What
type of protein is
expressed by the BCRABL1
driver mutation and
constitutively active cytosolic
or non-receptor
tyrosine kinase? What is
the importance of the
T315I point mutation?
confers resistance
to many of the drugs
including imatinib.
What drugs are active
against CML harboring
this mutation?
Panatinib and asiminib. What
are some class toxicities?
Diarrhea, rash edema,
periorbital edema,
bone marrow suppression,
CYP3A4, drug
interactions, and more.
Serious and potentially
life-threatening
toxicities of penatinib.
We see acute interval
prolongation now.
I'm not going to ask
you to memorize that.
So let's talk about
our EGFR inhibitors
and bevacizumab, the
VEGF inhibitor. And this
is in the context of
colorectal cancer.
The MABs are competitive
inhibitors of these tyrosine
kinases, these epidermal
growth factor receptors.
Same mechanism we saw
as with the other ones.
Same deal.
Cetuximab also causes
antibody dependent cellular
cytotoxicity which means it
attracts NK cells which then
insert its granzymes causing
cell death and it will
also cause some the complement
mediated cell death.
Now this is an important
feature here that I put in
red not effective in tumors
expressing this oncogene
KRAS KRAS you'll hear it
different ways oncogene and
look at the frequency of
that 40 to 50 percent of
colorectal tumors so the tumor
must be identified for its
presence or absence of
kras oncogene if it's
absent it's called wild
type kras it's not mutated
bevacizumab binds vegfa
and just neutralizes
it it prevents it from
binding to its receptor
Therefore, new blood vessels
are not made in the tumor.
What do I want
to tell you here?
Just for cetuximab, we're
talking about colorectal
cancer. That's the one
I want you to remember.
You can just know that
some other cancers as well.
Panatumumab, same deal. They
have to be the KRAS wild type.
Can't be the mutated type.
And bevacizumab got a number of
indications, including
colorectal cancer.
So the patient would get
the full FOX, the cetuximab,
the bevacizumab, depending
on the cancer type.
Cetuximab and panitumumab are
ineffective in tumors
with what mutation?
KRAS-Oncuchene,
which is a GTPA's.
What are the target
and disease treated
by both Cetuximab
and Panatumumab?
Well, we're only
talking about metastatic
colorectal cancer
at the moment.
And Bevacizumab,
it blocks DEGF.
And Cytotoxic Chemotherapies,
well, we talked
about full phallus,
full fury.
We see Cetuximab and
Bevacizumab added on to it.
and serious and potential
serious potentially life
-threatening toxicities well
egfr inhibitors epidermal
growth factor inhibitors
diarrhea rash electrolyte
disturbances lung
toxicity infusion reaction
with the vessel inhibitors
hemorrhage poor wound
healing hypertension
thrombosis gi perforation
infusion reactions and this
is going to depend on the
patient on the type of
cancer on a lot of things.
And HER2 inhibitors.
Now, we're talking
about HER2 positive
breast cancer. I'm
going to be giving you
several classes of drugs
for breast cancers.
These are widely used.
Many people, unfortunately,
have breast cancer
and are being treated
for it and treat it
successfully in many cases.
Trastuzumab, pertuzumab,
adutrastuzumab. So
it's called trastuzumab
already. So you know
trastuzumab. This is an
antibody drug conjugate,
conjugated with this
cytotoxic product.
And then we have a
small molecule. How
do we know it's small?
It ends in tinib.
Trastuzumab and pertuzumab.
Well, they bind to the
HER2 in different spots.
That prevents a ligand
-independent dimerization,
which induces the
internalization of the
drug receptor complex,
and also it induces
the antibody-dependent
cellular cytotoxicity.
Now to trastuzumab. Oh, by
the way, the trastuzumab
and pertuzumab are frequently
used together because
they do act at different
sites on that same receptor,
and together they work
better than either one alone.
So let's talk about this
antibody drug conjugate.
Here we have our antibody
carrying the payload and
binds to its specific
receptor HER2 taken in and
degraded and now the microtubule
inhibitor is released
inside the cell in
high concentrations to
produce the effect specifically
inside the tumor cell
or any cell that's
overexpressing HER2 receptors.
Now, this is a great idea.
The toxicity can
occur, especially if
these linkers are not
tight. and the cytotoxic
mitosis inhibitor
is released too soon
before it even gets
to the cancer cell.
Here's a picture
of our trastuzumab
TDM1. That's the mTansine one.
We have our lopatinib
in here. So it works
in here just like all
the rest of them do.
All the rest of those tenibs.
and trastuzumab is also
combined with the hyaluronidase
now so that it can be
given subcutaneously.
So it is a first
-line agent together
with the taxane,
the doxorubicin,
the cyclophosphamide,
possibly the
pertuzumab, and other
types of cancers.
and that's basically
the story with
the therapeutic
use of these drugs
toxicities well
trastuzumab pertuzumab
they are associated
with heart failure
decreased left
ventricular ejection
fraction congestive
heart failure we saw
this one with
cyclophosphamide also.
We saw the cardiomyopathy
with the doxorubicin,
anthracycline, highest
risk with anthracycline
chemotherapy regimen,
which is a common regimen.
Infusion reactions,
lung toxicity on and on,
pregnancy, embryo fetal death,
increased risk of cardiac
toxicity, and now we have
hepatotoxicity with liver
failure. This is the
mitosis toxin that we're
talking about here.
Epatinib, oral, all the other
things we saw with tenibs.
The axon, same as
with the other tenibs.
Resistance, just exactly
what you would expect.
We're talking about
breast cancer, which would
be the advanced or
metastatic breast cancer.
Others, but we're talking
about lipatinib in the
context of breast cancer,
so that's what to remember.
Toxicities, same thing as
we saw with the other ones,
including
cardiotoxicity and now
keep the interval prolongation.
Learn at once and it carries
through with all the rest.
mechanistically
how do trastuzumab
and pertuzumab work together
HER2 they bind to different
epitopes on HER2 how
does lopatinib interfere
well inside prevents the
autophosphorylation activation
and signaling pathway
antibody drug conjugates
this cytotoxic payload.
And combination regimen here,
the tank's taxane,
plus or minus, usually
plus, doxorubicin,
cyclophosphamide, trastuzumab,
plus or minus pertuzumab, and
heart failure, lung toxin,
fusion toxicities are
very serious potential adverse
effects of trastuzumab.
okay let's talk about
our cyclin dependent
kinases this is for the
treatment of hormone receptor
positive HER2 negative
breast cancer so hormone
receptor positive what
hormones are we talking about
estrogen receptor mainly
estrogen receptor positive
It could be
progesterone receptor
positive too, but
HER2 negative.
So they end in cyclib,
which I spelled wrong.
Cyclib, palbocyclib.
It's easy to remember,
cyclin-dependent.
So this is how they work.
This box, this purple
box, is retinoblastoma.
And it is complexed
with these two proteins,
E2F, DP1.
And this complex is inactive.
Now we get our cyclin
-dependent kinases here, 4 and
6, is going to release
the retinoblastoma by
phosphorylating it. and as
a result E2F and DP1 are
also released and these are
active and that will push
the cell cycle through
this G1 to S transition.
Cycle independent
kinases are these
gatekeepers at the G1
to S transition point.
Well they're oral
so everything we've
heard about oral
is true with M2.
Reversible inhibitors
of CDK4 and
CDK6, cycle
-independent kinases,
preventing the
progression from G1 to
S phase, leading to
cell cycle arrest,
apoptosis,
breast cancer, hormone
receptor positive,
HER2 negative, advanced
or metastatic. Now, Well,
they're given together
with this drug, with
this group of drugs called
aromatase inhibitors.
Inhibitor.
Why? Well, aromatase converts
androgens to estrogens.
We're talking about hormone
receptor positive
cancers, estrogen.
aromatase reduces
concentrations of estrogen and
therefore reduces estrogen's
effect on these hormone receptor
positive cancers so these
two together aromatase
inhibitors plus the cdk
4646 inhibitor are effective
when you they're most effective
when used together and
they are less toxic than
the chemotherapy regimens.
We talked about the chemotherapies
and their toxicities
and all the different
drugs that are used in the
treatment of breast cancer.
For individuals who can,
who have hormone receptor
positive, but HER2 negative,
this could be a really
a preferred therapy.
Toxicities will bone marrow
suppression, skin reactions,
lung, infection, and we get the
inflammation in the
mouth, and on and on.
We see these over and
over, but those are
pretty manageable
compared to some of
them that we saw with
the chemotherapies.
Now our PARP inhibitors.
Okay, PARP. We have to know
what this acronym means.
PolyADP ribose polymerase.
PolyADP ribose polymerase
inhibitors. These
are located in the cell
nucleus and they detect,
polyADP ribose detects
and initiates immediate
cellular responses
to metabolic chemical
or radiation induced
single strand DNA brain.
And the poly-ADP ribose
is formed by the poly
-ADP ribose polymerases.
So we are inhibiting
that. And by inhibiting
PARPs, we inhibit this
repair action, this
repair system pathway.
PARP, PARIB, maybe it's not
so hard to remember the name.
olaparib is the only
one that I'm asking you
to remember it was the
first one in the group
you can see that it's
useful for all variety
of different cancers
hormone related cancers
and the toxicities pretty
much what you'd expect effect.
Now B-cell malignancy,
anti-CD20 agents. CD20 is
expressed on mature B
-cells, all the mature B
-cells in the periphery
except for plasma cells.
Rituximab has been
around many years,
decades, and is
still in common use.
Rituximab is here, this
particular epitope,
and then we the other
CD20 inhibitors, the
different epitopes, the,
here's rituximab, so
rituximab binds to
CD20, you see that here,
and that will draw an
NK cell to it which
will then kill the B
lymphocyte, complement
mediated to kill the B
glymphosate, and this
is an apoptotic pathway
that also appears
to be associated as a
mechanism of toxicity.
Anticancer users have
so many rituximab,
so many CD20 positive cancers.
Here is another
acronym, RCHOP. This is
very common. CHOP
is cyclophosphamide,
doxorubicin, which is
hydroxydonorubicin,
vincristine, which is
oncovin, and prednisone.
And R has been added
to this regimen,
and it has certainly
improved the efficacy.
And immune disorders.
Look at this big list
of immune disorders
that rituximab is
useful for. You don't
have to memorize this.
You should remember
rheumatoid arthritis.
Adverse effects.
infection it's an
immunosuppressant tumor
lysis syndrome we're
talking about b-cell
tumors severe skin
reactions reaction of
latent infections hbv
possibly progressive
let me see if I can
remember the name
progressive
multifocal
leukoencephalopathy and
we have a number of other
issues so patients should
be screened for HBV
tuberculosis, hepatitis C HIV
if they are at risk for those
okay it took the map
targets what antigen on what
types of immune cells
cd20 on b cells mature b
cells in the periphery
mechanism of action antibody
dependent cellular site
of toxicity complement
-dependent cytotoxicity,
and likely also apoptosis.
Patients should be screened
for what infections?
HBV, tuberculosis, HCV, HIV.
And hyaluronidase allows it to
be administered subcutaneously.
CDK4 and PARP inhibitors.
And here we go.
So, CDK4-6 prevents the
release of retinoblastoma,
tumor suppressor
protein, prevents the
progression from G1 to
S phase of the cycle.
PARP inhibitors block
DNA damage response
pathways in patients
with deleterious
BRCA1-2 tumors, you
should remember that,
which prevents tumor
cells from repairing
DNA, making them
vulnerable to apoptosis.
And multiple myeloma,
we have three groups,
four groups rather, that
we'll be talking about.
We're going to look at these.
So we'll talk about each
one of those individually.
So the IMIDs.
immunomodulatory MI drugs,
IMIDs, immunomodulatory drugs.
Lenolinamide is the one that's
used far more than the others.
Oral, these are oral
drugs, these IMDs.
Okay, I'll talk about the
mechanism on the next slide.
Lenolinamide is the
preferred one for
the treatment of
multiple myeloma.
and other, a few other cancers.
The adverse effects include
neutropenia, thrombocytopenia,
okay, we're getting
used to that,
thromboembolic events,
peripheral neuropathy,
getting used to that,
hepatotoxicity, okay,
hypersensitivity, and
now we see this really
terrible hypersensitivity
skin reaction
and systemic
hypersensitivity reaction
contraindicated in
pregnancy, which I'll get to.
All right, the mechanism binds
to this protein
called cereblon.
Cereblon is important
for or physiologically,
biochemistry-wise, for
recruiting all of these proteins.
And the purpose of recruiting
all of those proteins
is to lead to this
ubiquination of this IKZF,
which will then go into the
proteasome for degradation.
And this action
causes the death
of the multiple myeloma cells.
And these are the
definitions of
the acronyms on
the previous page.
So what are the effects?
Immunomodulatory, makes
sense from the name.
Antiangiogenic, antineoplastic.
g1 arrest or apoptosis
the thing is with these
immunomodulatory drugs
mechanism a number of sites
of action have been
identified the actual
mechanism by which it produces
cancer cell killing is
supposed but we'll look
at what we can see direct
anti-tumor effects
with It's a cell cycle
arrest, and the effect is
with BCL2 family members.
Now, this is an important
part of multiple
myeloma, which is NF
-kappa-B signaling.
NF-kappa-B is part of
the pathophysiology
of multiple myeloma.
So these drugs, through
that mechanism that
led to ubiquination,
blocks NF-kappa-B
signaling. I'm going to go
into more detail on that.
And it also inhibits
the inflammatory
cytokine IL-6 production.
It inhibits multiple
myeloma cell adhesion
to bone marrow stromal
cells. It decreases
angiogenesis due to
inhibition of cytokine
and growth factor
production and release.
It enhances cell
-mediated cytotoxicity.
So it's got all these
number of effects,
and these drugs are
used specifically
for the treatment
of multiple myeloma.
Now, pregnancy
contraindication.
They are embryotoxic. They
cause severe developmental
deformities, which we
can see here with these
babies in this picture,
drawing of a little boy.
Stunted limb growth. This
is called focal melia.
You can see how the
arms just did not grow.
There are hands, but the
arms did not grow. The
legs did not grow and
other abnormalities as well
some babies die some
people grow to be adults
patients should male
patients and female patients
should use should make
sure the condoms are used
proteasome inhibitors this
is bortezomib is the one
that i have a star on it
is the first one that was
developed and is still
used mechanism of action
I'll talk about on the next
page the typical adverse
effects that we keep seeing
over and over and over
okay proteasome inhibitors
so we see the proteasome
right here and the
proteasome is like the trash
can it will take these
ubiquinated proteins will
come into the proteasome
and will be degraded into
their peptides and amino
acids and will be reused.
Now, one of the other
things that this proteasome
does is it causes release
of nucleophactor kappa B.
And it does this because NF
-kappa B is kept inactivated
by some protein called
inhibitor of kappa B.
So it goes through the
proteasome and it removes the
NF-kappa B from its inhibitor
and therefore releases NF
-kappa B and since multiple
pathophysiology of NF-kappa
B is for multiple myeloma.
I did not say that well.
Pathophysiology for
multiple myeloma
is related to levels
of NF-kappa B.
So that's how the proteasome
inhibitors work by
probably related also to
the buildup of all the
trash here, the ubiquinated
proteins that are non
-functional, as well as
the release of NF-kappa B,
or preventing the release
of NF-kappa B, I should say.
And this is just another
picture showing the
different pathways interrelated
that we talked about.
And now daratumumab, obviously
a monoclonal antibody.
CD38 is its target.
CD38 overexpressed on
multiple myeloma cells.
but there are low
levels on normal cells.
So that's what makes
CD38 an attractive
target. We get the
same concepts here.
Complement-dependent
cytotoxicity, ADCC,
and the FC-mediated cross
-linking leading to apoptosis.
Multiple myeloma, newly
diagnosed induction treatment,
and also high-risk
candidates, and here we go.
So daratumumab,
multiple myeloma,
muumumu, myeloma,
bone marrow toxicity, infusion
reactions, latent infection,
screen for HBV,
****** zoster prophylaxis.
It all follows based
on the mechanism.
dexamethasone is a
glucocorticoid i put a star
on it because it's part of
this regimen dexamethasone
is a very important
drug to be familiar with
it works like all of the
other glucocorticoids
and it's got some features
of its own but i'll
leave that for another
lecture just remember that
dexamethasone is a
glucocorticoid it is an anti
-inflammatory It suppresses
neutrophil migration,
inflammatory mediators,
and on and on. Like all
glucocorticoids, it has a
number of different actions.
What is the initial therapy for
standard risk multiple myeloma?
So, bortezomib, lenalidomide,
and dexamethasone,
which of course has
an acronym, VRD, based
on the brand names.
What drug is added for
initial therapy in high
-risk patients or candidates
for hematopoietic
stem cell transplant?
Teratumumab, CD38 inhibitor.
What is the mechanism
of action of each of the
drugs in the regimen?
So proteasome inhibitor
prevents proteolysis of
ubiquininated proteins and
release of NF-kappa B. The
immunomodulator drugs recruit
substrates, resulting in
ubiquination and degradation
of transcription factors.
Dexamethasone induces apoptosis
of multiple myeloma cells.
Daratumumab induces
ADCC, complement
-dependent cellular
cytotoxicity apoptosis.
And what drugs are known to be
embryotoxic and
present in the *****?
The immunomodulatory drugs.
now immune checkpoint
inhibitors these are very hot
meaning widely widely
used gaining indications
frequently ccla4 inhibitors
pd1 inhibitors and pdl1
inhibitors These are immune
checkpoint inhibitors.
Immune checkpoints are
regulations of regulators,
I should say, of the immune
system cells that cause
downregulation of immune
system attack. So, the
immune checkpoint inhibitors
are intended to inhibit
that down-regulation of the
immune system, therefore
freeing the immune system
to attack the cancer.
And here's a picture of
an idea of how it works.
We have our PD-1, and let's
see what we have here.
I'm going to go
start right here.
Checkpoint 1, CTLA-4.
You may remember the
CTLA-4 is a co-receptor
that activation
of it is required for
T-cell activation.
So when the CTLA-4 is
expressed on T-cells, that will
downregulate the T-cell. So,
any drug that would block
CTLA-4 would prevent that
T-cell inhibitory effect.
Checkpoint 2, PD-1.
PD-1, expressed on
T-cells, is program
death 1. That's what PD
-1 means. So activation
of PD-1 activates
the signaling pathway
that leads to apoptosis
of the T cell.
PD-L1 is a ligand,
the ligand that binds
PD-1 and activates
that apoptotic
pathway. PD-L1 is
located on tumor cells.
PD-1, as I said before,
is located on T cells.
Therefore, blocking
PD-1 with a drug
will prevent the
ligand binding.
Also, blocking PD-L1 will block
the ligand binding to PD-1.
And blocking both
of them, well,
obviously it prevents
the activation of
the cell death
response in the T cell.
Oh, I just want to
mention one more thing.
It also increases,
activation of the PD-1
also increases regulatory
T cells, these Tregs,
or Tregs, that are
checkpoint inhibitors
as well. So we're
blocking that effect too.
So CTLA-4 inhibitor
ipilimumab blocks CTLA-4,
allows enhanced T-cell
activation and proliferation.
Melanoma was the
first use of it,
metastatic melanoma,
and it picked up
other uses as well.
So PD-1 inhibitors,
we have pertuzumab,
not pertuzumab, we have
pembrolizumab, see I get
these names mixed up too,
and nivolumab,
so MAPs.
I explained this on
the previous slide,
the previous slide.
okay immune related adverse
events immune related
so now we have an up
regulation of the t
-cell response so the t
-cells are active and they're
going to be active
against the tumor cell
and active against non
-tumor cells so they are
immune related adverse
events inflammatory skin
reactions. GI is the
diarrhea and the colitis and
the hepatotoxicity and
the endocrinopathies by
potentially causing
inflammation of the pituitary.
Pneumonitis, autoimmune
hemolytic anemia,
hemophagocytic
lymphohistiocytosis.
and all of these
effects seem to be
more common with
the CTLA inhibitors
than with the PD-1
or PD-L1 inhibitors.
Early recognition,
timely intervention,
cessation of therapy
if necessary are
essential for managing
these adverse effects.
Now the CAR T cells. This is
the last group
we'll talk about.
The cells are removed
from the patient, and then
they are modified outside
the patient's body.
And then they are put
back in the patient.
So they are engineered,
the T cells are
engineered to recognize
specific tumor antigens.
The CD19 were the first.
So these CAR T cells
that recognize CD19
for the treatment of
certain B cell cancer.
CD19 is also expressed
on B cells. We saw
CD20, we see CD19 on
the tumor cells. Now,
this, here's a Leclusyl,
Lusyl, Silolusyl,
Autolusyl, Miralusyl,
Lusyl, Lusyl, Lusyl. So now
you know that's a CAR T cell.
BCMA targeting, this is
for multiple myeloma.
And now this is a
newer one to the group
that I'll talk about
on the next slide.
This is the only one
I'm asking you to
remember, the tisogen
leclusyl. So if you see
that leucyl, you know
I'm talking about the
CAR T-cell. It's CD19,
so think B-cell. B
-cell, acute lymphoblastic
leukemia, diffuse large cell
lymphoma, follicular lymphoma,
methyl cell lymphoma.
The BCMA, the multiple myeloma,
and this anti-so-called
MAGE A4 synovial sarcoma.
So this is the first one
that's actually a sarcoma.
The others are hematologic.
Cytokine release
syndrome. So these
engineered CAR T
cells are activated.
And they can release large
amounts of cytokines.
and that these cytokines
pro-inflammatory cytokines
can cause this acute
systemic inflammatory
syndrome all over the
body fever multi-organ and
organ dysfunction it can
happen quickly or after
weeks so monitor hospitalized
at the first sign
Supportive care is important.
Neurotoxicity syndrome.
Encephalopathy.
Visual and auditory
hallucinations.
What is the mechanistic concept
of immune checkpoint
inhibitors?
Immune checkpoints
are inhibitory
signals that limit
T-cell activation,
blocking the immune
checkpoints. And we're
talking about CD8 T-cells
here, because they're
the ones that attack
the cancer. allows them
to recognize cancer
cells expressing antigens
recognized by the T
-cells and eliminate them.
Many solid tumors,
immune-related
adverse reactions,
and infusion reactions.
What is the mechanistic concept
of the CAR T-cell drugs?
Genetically engineered
to express artificial T
-cell receptors targeting
specific tumor antigens.
Both the antigen
binding and the T-cell
activating functions are
combined in one receptor.
What are some serious
and potentially life
-threatening toxicities
of the CAR T-cells?
Cytokine release syndrome,
immune effector cell,
neurotoxicity syndrome.
And here's the summary.
These are the various oncogenic
pathways that have
been targeted.
and this is just a
recap of the mechanisms
and pharmacology this
is a picture of the
tyrosine kinase inhibitors
and our CTLA-4 and PD
-1 and PD-L1 inhibitors,
and the CAR T cell.
And the answers
to the questions.
And that's it.
So thank you for
your attention.
I know that this probably
seems very overwhelming.
If you can organize it,
see what are the concepts
common to everything,
the common thread, that
can minimize the amount
of learning you have to
do because you can just
apply one to the other.